a lot of the guys are sweethearts deep
down well it's perfect they're just
dealing with a fair amount of trauma
permission to blow them to hell captain
and we're quite certain their pirates
hard to say
one appears to be a heavy set woman in a
silk dressing gown everybody hi
thank you all for assembling this
incredibly
gifted cast because i they've had me
laughing all morning and i don't know
how you all sort of
got through the day but reese i want to
start with you you and ty have been
collaborating from what i can see for at
least you know the better part of the
last two decades but why this project
and why now
well i was brought on board and uh you
know
he got the job
he was tired he didn't have any choice
i was forced to do it once they said we
want you
um and i i had an inkling that it was
going to happen when i knew taika was
involved and it was a comedy series so i
just was sitting next to the computer
and eventually the email did pop up
um and uh so there here i am and you
know his best decision i ever made was
was uh was to say yes to david he
decided i was the right guy and uh so
yeah
i love it
i just love working with rhys we're good
together you know nothing's going to
tear us apart
that's against the world man yeah it's
always been like that and i wouldn't say
i've had it since this because like i
remember the first time i saw that funny
t name was uh in the credits for flight
of the concord so thank you all for this
david i want to bring it to you next
though the great thing about this show
you already have this great cast but
like so many of the projects that uh you
guys work on there's the opportunity for
cameos and historical figures so i'm
just curious you already did blackbeard
and so many folks names of folks know is
there somebody you'd like to come in to
play like a wild character pirate that
you haven't done yet and who would that
want to be i mean mike i the person that
i would really like to get is russell
crowe because i think he'd actually be
terrifying and i think wow
so russell pro if you're watching it i
knew you
didn't even do the show i'll text him
he'll do it yeah
it just takes him
yeah i'm sure you can't do that
it's so great tyco that you're playing
blackbeard like again i spoke to leslie
today and she was just like cracking up
about everything that you were doing
with it and loved it and i know that
pirates that are playing real characters
they got to learn about those did you
find any blackbeard lore because i've
become a bit of a pirate expert recently
thanks to documentaries and a lot of
alone time here at home
you've learned a lot about blackbeard
you probably watched that netflix one
yeah i did i did as well i started
watching it and then i saw the actor and
i was like oh he's got such a good
bristolian accent and i was like yeah i
can't do that and i was like he's done
it so i can't do that and i said you've
lost confidence i said to david i don't
know i don't want to do an accent and
he's like just do your own accent
i mean like the idea of just playing
dressing up like those pirates which is
pretty boring to me because everyone
does it all the time so yeah yeah yeah
halloween costume but we're david and
then david what you you you came up with
this idea i mean what just
in talking how you talk and talking how
both of you talk it's nice it's like
low-key you know it's not like ah i'm
blackbeard it's just like oh i'm lucky
it's like like yeah as soon as you hear
it
yeah
so automatically it writes differently
automatically you know where to go with
that character because it's like
taiga has like cat energy and rhys has
like dog energy and they sound like they
sound and it just kind of it just kind
of works and you don't have to worry
about coming up with like yoldy
stuff yeah and i wouldn't want to see
leslie be anything but leslie when she's
yelling at people like i really do oh
yeah and leslie do all of the leslie
things yeah and then making the world
where like somebody can come from the
bronx and like yeah that's it
i love it that's the best part about it
i literally the minute they said taika
plays blackbeard i'm like that's the
joke right there you don't need to write
anything else that is
that's awesome i love it i mean when you
came out the first time you had the
beard and all the stuff and like it was
like you don't have to do anything you
just have to have words come out of your
face because
yeah it makes you feel crazy as well
dressed like dicks you got this big
beard that's super uncomfortable and
long hair that's getting in your mouth
all the time and you're dressing these
hot mad max leather outfits and
and no one really talks to you
you feel like there's like something
about drinking like that no one hangs
out with you and then i had jojo was the
same with the hitler outfit like you
just alienate yourself on set i don't
know about this
you played very much he felt a bit
lonely and
that angered me um i spoke i spoke to
you right
yeah you did i mean you yeah you
you're my only friend
uh garrett i definitely want to ask you
really quickly though because the whole
premise of this is somebody going
through like this whole sort of like
midlife crisis yeah yeah i'm in the
midlife crisis no you're not
i did not say that i was just curious if
there was anything that you would want
to do if you were in that moment i would
never call you in that moment ever
that's rude
um if i was in the moment of the midlife
crisis which i am i think everybody on
this call and most people meet him would
want to be uh take away teaching
two midlife crises a year
but they're just small ones you joined
the club the midlife crisis club you get
stamps they made me prison
[Laughter]
i will just say nobody else's is half as
entertaining if this is your midlife
crisis let's look at the last five years
i mean going from like thor and then
what we do in the shadows and
reservoir dogs and just all of this
stuff and i really legitimately asked
this as a person that followed him
around for six months on jojo rabbit on
the awards tour and i was exhausted with
him doing that and he was also working
on a marvel movie in a soccer movie next
goal wins and all that do you sleep like
legitimately do you sleep yeah i've got
and i've got i've got an aura ring and
it tells me
my sleep thing at the moment i'll bring
it up but if you want to come up with
another yes
but my sleep is um
currently 86 which is optimal pretty
good 86 hours
86 a score of 86. so total sleep was
eight hours 43 minutes oh wow that's a
good one rem was suffering and only an
hour
i was trying to show you my sleep good
where's my um well there you go 8 54.
that's great reese you're that's pretty
good for me all right anyway gentlemen
this is a blast i'm sorry my chair broke
and throughout me
look at you this interview is going
great
you